♪
>> Jesse: KINGDOMS DON'T WORK
HERE IN AMERICA.
ENGLAND LEARNED THAT LESSON THE
HARD WAY AND THEN WE ALL LEARNED
ABOUT IT IN SCHOOL.
BUT SOME PEOPLE JUST DON'T GET
IT.
THEY GROW UP THINKING THEY
DESERVE TO BE KING.
>> I ORDER YOU TO BE QUIET.
>> ORDER?
>> I'M YOUR KING.
>> WELL, I DIDN'T VOTE FOR YOU.
>> YOU DON'T VOTE FOR KINGS.
>> WELL HOW DID YOU BECOME KING
THEM.
>> THE LADY OF THE LAKE.
HER ARM CLAD IN THE PUREST
SHIMMERING HELD A LOT OF
EXCALIBER FROM THE BOSOM OF THE
WATER SIGNIFYING BY DIVINE
PROVIDENCE I ARTHUR WAS TO CARRY
EXCALIBER.
>> PEOPLE WHO WANT TO BECOME
KING IMMEDIATELY ATTRACTED TO
REPUBLICANS.
PEOPLE THINK WHENEVER THEY GET
ELECTED THEY CAN DO WHATEVER
THEY WANT.
LOOK AT LOS ANGELES, KAREN BASS
WAS JUST ELECTED MAYOR, REMEMBER
HER?
SHE IS THE ANTI-GUN
CONGRESSWOMAN WHO HAD TWO PIECES
STOLEN FROM HER HOUSE AND NOW
SHE IS RUNNING AMERICA'S MOST
CHAOTIC CITY.
AND WHAT DID SHE DO ON HER FIRST
DAY?
GIVE HERSELF ULTIMATE
UNRESTRICTED POWER?
>> MY FIRST ACT AS MAYOR WILL BE
TO DECLARE A STATE OF EMERGENCY
ON HOMELESSNESS.
[APPLAUSE]
, A STATE OF EMERGENCY ON
HOMELESSNESS.
MY EMERGENCY DECLARATION WILL
RECOGNIZE THE SEVERITY OF OUR
CRISIS AND BREAK NEW GROUND TO
MAXIMIZE OUR ABILITY TO URGENTLY
MOVE PEOPLE INSIDE AND TO DO SO
FOR GOOD.
>> Jesse: YOU SEE, THE BEST WAY
TO BECOME QUEEN IS DECLARE AN
EMERGENCY.
REMEMBER THE COVID LOCKDOWNS?
WE HAD KING CUOMO IN NEW YORK.
KING NEWSOM IN CALIFORNIA.
QUEEN WHITMER IN MICHIGAN ALL
ANOINTED BY FAUCI, THE EMPEROR.
QUEEN KAREN TOOK NOTES AND NOW
SHE HAS THE POWER.
THIS EXPLAINS WHY KAMALA WAS SO
EXCITED FOR HER OLD FRIEND.
>> MADAM MAYOR.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS]
>> Jesse: LOS ANGELES CITY
COUNCIL GAVE THE EMERGENCY
POWERS A THUMBS UP LAST NIGHT.
THEY COULDN'T DENY L.A.'S FIRST
MAYOR HER CROWN.
COULD I DECLARE AN EMERGENCY IF
YOU DON'T LIKE SOMETHING?
I DON'T LIKE TAXES.
THAT'S MY EMERGENCY.
SO, WHAT DOES QUEEN KAREN GET?
WELL, $100 MILLION TO BUILD
HOUSES FOR THE HOMELESS.
NO OVERSIGHT.
NO BIDDING.
QUEEN KAREN CAN JUST GIVE THE
CONTRACTS OUT TO ALL OF HER
FRIENDS AND DONORS.
NO QUESTIONS ASKED.
PUT HOMELESS IN SWANKY HOTEL
ROOMS.
HAS THE POWER TO SEIZE YOUR
PROPERTY AND GIVE TO A HOMELESS
PERSON.
DON'T WORRY, QUEEN KAREN SAYS IT
PROBABLY WON'T COME TO THAT.
JUST LIKE WHEN BIDEN SAID HE
WOULDN'T HAVE VAX MANDATES OR
WHEN HE SAID WE WOULDN'T SEND
PATRIOT MISSILES TO UKRAINE AND
THEN HE DID.
BUT THIS TIME THEY ARE BEING FOR
REAL.
THEY HAVE THE POWER TO TAKE YOUR
HOME AND GIVE IT TO A DRUG
ADDICT.
BUT PROBABLY WON'T DO THAT.
NOW, THERE ARE PLENTY OF EMPTY
HOUSES IN L.A.
MILLIONAIRES, SECOND OR THIRD
HOMES.
ALL THE CELEBRITIES' BEACH
HOUSES BUT I DON'T THINK QUEEN
KAREN IS GOING TO SEND ANY
HOMELESS PEOPLE THERE THOSE ARE
HER BIGGEST DONORS.
HUNTER'S MALIBU MANSION IS
EMPTY.
IS HE SHACKING UP WITH POP IN
D.C.
YOU CAN FIT A FEW DOZEN ADDICTS
IN THERE.
NO.
WHEN QUEEN KAREN SEIZES HOUSES
IT, WILL BE PEOPLE WHO CAN'T
AFFORD EXPENSIVE LAWYERS.
THE PEOPLE WHO CAUSED THE
HOMELESS PROBLEM SHOULDN'T BE IN
CHARGE OF FIXING IT.
THEY ARE NOT QUALIFIED.
LOS ANGELES BLOWS A BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR ON THE HOMELESS
AND IT GETS WORSE EVERY YEAR.
THERE'S OVER 40,000 HOMELESS ON
THE STREET.
THEY CONTROL ENTIRE BLOCKS, SETS
UP TENTS WHEREVER THEY WANT.
WHY PAY MILLIONS FOR BEACHFRONT
PROPERTY WHEN YOU CAN JUST CLAIM
THE LAND FOR FREE?
THEY KEEP THROWING BILLIONS AT
THE PROBLEM BUT IT DOESN'T GO
AWAY.
IT GROWS.
QUEEN KAREN DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
IT'S NOT ALL ABOUT HOUSING.
>> IF THERE'S PEOPLE IN LOS
ANGELES WHO WORK FULL-TIME JOBS
WHO GO HOME TO TENTS BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T AFFORD THE RENT.
>> Jesse: I DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
THIS ISN'T A HOUSING PROBLEM.
IT'S NOT A MONEY PROBLEM.
IT'S DEEPER.
DRUG ADDICTION AND MENTAL
ILLNESS ON THE LIST GOVERNMENT
HOUSING.
>> FROM OHIO TELLS ME HE HAS A
DRUG PROBLEM, IS ESTRANGED FROM
HIS FAMILY.
HAS ALSO SAID NO TO REPEATED
OFFERS OF SHELTER.
>> ALMOST JAIL LIKE,
PENITENTIARY LIKE ALMOST.
I DON'T KNOW.
FREEDOM BEING LIKE HOMELESS.
>> Jesse: TIME FOR DEMOCRATS TO
ADMIT THEY ARE OVER HEIR HEADS.
GIVING UNLIMITED POWER AND MONEY
ISN'T GOING TO CHANGE.
THIS EVEN THE HOMELESS KNOW THEY
ARE COMING UP WITH THEIR OWN
SOLUTIONS TO SURVIVE ON THE
STREETS.
>> IT'S A SOLID WELL-BUILT
WOODEN STRUCTURE, PROPPED UP BY
METAL CARTS AND CAR BATTERIES.
A POWER CORD UNPLUGGED TRAILS
DOWN THE SIDEWALK, WHICHS IS
PILED HIGH WITH ASSORTED POWER
TOOLS AND ELECTRONICS.
>> I WAS ORIGINALLY IN A TENT
AND WHEN THE SAN STATION COMES
ONCE EVERY TWO WEEKS THEY HAVE
YOU TAKE YOUR TENT DOWN AND
CLEAR ALL YOUR STUFF OUT.
WHAT I HAD AN IDEA JUST TO
BUILDING IS ON WHEELS.
>> Jesse: NOT EVERY HOMELESS GUY
IS THAT NICE.
[SHOUTING]
[BLEEP] [BLEEP]
>> Jesse: L.A. IS HELL.
IT'S DANGEROUS FOR THE HOMELESS
AND THE TAXPAYERS.
AT ANY GIVEN MOMENT CAN YOU GET
SMASHED OVER THE HEAD BY A JUNKY
ON A BAD TRIP.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED TO OLYMPIC
MEDALIST KIM GLASS SHE WAS
MINDING HER OWN BUSINESS,
WALKING OUT OF A RESTAURANT IN
BROAD DAYLIGHT AND BOOM SOME
HOMELESS MANIAC CRACKS HER IN
THE FACE WITH A PIECE OF METAL,
JUST ANOTHER DAY IN L.A.
AND IF YOU SOMEHOW ESCAPE
GETTING A BEATING, YOU MIGHT
JUST GET COVERED IN FECES.
>> SIR, WHY ARE YOU THROWING
FECES AT PEOPLE?
>> WHO?
>> YOU THROUGH FECES AT THIS
GENTLEMAN.
>> YOU JUST HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
I'M HALF PARALYZED.
I'M BLIND.
I HAVE NO CAR FOR NINE YEARS.
>> WE OFFERED TO HELP THE MAN
WITH SERVICES FOR THE HOMELESS,
BUT.
>> SIR, DO YOU NEED HELP IN THE
CITY IS OFFERING HELP.
>> QUIT BOTHERING ME.
I DON'T KNOW HELP.
HE NEEDS HELP.
>> Jesse: FOR A BLIND GUY HE HAS
PRETTY GOOD AIM.
THIS IS WHO QUEEN KAREN WANTS TO
LIVE IN YOUR HOUSE, THE DOUG
FLUTIE OF DUTIY.
HE DOESN'T HAVE A FULL-TIME JOB.
HE'S NOT HAVING TROUBLE PAYING
RENT.
HE IS MENTALLY ILL.
AND HE DOESN'T WANT HELP.
HE WOULD RATHER SMEAR FECES